[Music]
welcome to using Cloud native tools to
strengthen your platform security
posture and manage risk I'm Tim
wingarder a product manager on Google
Cloud security Command Center later I'll
be joined by mob check satorski an
engineering manager at acada for those
joining for the first time I'll do a
quick recap of what security Command
Center or SEC is then I'll jump into
what's new across the product and
finally I'll spend time chatting with
Patrick from ocado about how he and his
organization are using security Command
Center let's Dive Right In
security Command Center is Google
Cloud's native security solution that
federates security insights across your
organization you can think about it in
four areas of value first asset and
resource tracking you might have asked
yourself if I don't know what I have
deployed how can I secure it Cloud asset
inventory helps customers gain
visibility into their ever-expanding set
of assets and resources to understand
how much and of what they've got
deployed helping eliminate any security
blind spots
second it helps discover vulnerabilities
and detect potential misconfigurations
of those Cloud assets that might be
putting your organization at risk users
receive notifications about new or
updated findings in near real time to
drive action and reduce that risk third
is threat detection spotting malicious
activity and unauthorized Behavior
security Command Center can detect
threats such as malware crypto mining
Brute Force SSH outgoing a denial of
service attacks anomalous I am grants
and potential data exfiltration it also
can detect multiple types of container
runtime attacks fourth compliance
standard mapping simply security Command
Center helps customers maintain
compliance they can review reports to
ensure resources meet requirements set
forth by a variety of regulations and
Industry best practices like the CIS
benchmarks it brings all of this
together in one Central Tool across the
customer's entire gcp environment
throughout the security life cycle now
let's talk about what's new across this
functionality
first up we've released several
platform-wide updates that improve the
experience across the entirety of
security Command Center I'll quickly
cover three here first since you rely on
security Command Center for critical
security operations we've made it easier
to understand whether its ability to
protect your estate is impaired if
security Command Center detects the
defining publisher like security health
analytics or container threat detection
cannot produce findings or operate as
expected it will surface a special type
of finding along with instructions for
how to remediate so that you can benefit
from all of its capabilities next we've
significantly improved the experience
around consuming findings we've
standardized the information across the
different finding types and reorganize
the content so that they are easier to
understand than ever we've added a query
Builder that works together with those
standardized attributes allowing you to
quickly scope your views to view just
what you're interested in and lastly
we've rolled out in muting this allows
you to express simple or complex rules
across your organization to suppress
findings that fit a certain criteria
keeping you focused on the insights that
are most directly relevant to your
business
next we're making the findings the SEC
already provides around your estate's
assets misconfigurations vulnerabilities
and threats even more actionable with a
contextualized risk-oriented view
without impacting your environment
security Command Center will simulate
attacks to try and reach your estate's
high value targets the output of those
simulations informs a value that is
assigned to findings based on how they
contribute to the overall exposure of
your valuable assets this information
will help your team reason about the
findings in security Command Center and
take action on the most impactful
drivers of your organization's risk this
is coming to Early Access soon
complimenting everything I've mentioned
so far are improvements in Cloud asset
inventory and security command centers
posture management first Cloud asset
inventory allows you to understand
deeper details about your resources
through asset relationships for example
representing information about the app
engine application that a particular app
engine service is in
analytical querying is also available in
Early Access this capability allows you
to interrogate your Cloud estate
directly without having to export it to
bigquery First helping you understand
details about your current or past State
easier than ever before
Assets in Cloud asset inventory are the
foundation upon which scc's Early Access
custom posture detection are built you
can express your own detective controls
and SCC takes care of the rest producing
findings in real time and helping you
monitor your posture and finally we've
launched rapid vulnerability detection
in public preview this zero
configuration service automatically
discovers Network endpoints open ports
and installed software packages and
alerts you vulnerabilities like weak
credentials incomplete software
installation and expose admin interfaces
security Command Center continues its
innovation in the threat detection space
and recently made virtual machine threat
detection generally available this
unique agentless approach instruments
the hypervisor to offer nearly Universal
and hard to tamper with threat detection
additionally SEC and Chronicle have a
tight integration that lets customers
seamlessly pivot from a finding detail
and security command Center's console
into a curated alert view within
Chronicle from there users can
investigate the threat and quickly pivot
to Associated actions and events related
to the finding for a special deeper dive
on each of these check out my colleague
Tim peacock's Cloud threat detection
security talk from early this summer
we've worked hard on these updates and
are excited for you to check them out
next we're going to check in with
matchek from ocado to hear about ocado's
experience with SCC
welcome mat check uh can you introduce
yourself please
engineering manager at the color
technology
so avocado we leverage cutting-edge
technology and automation to transform
online grocery retail
our team of more than 2500 technologists
collaborate across 12 Development
Centers globally to innovate and build
our world-leading e-commerce fulfillment
and Logistics solution which is called
ocado smart platform
OSP enables our Global Retail Partners
to offer millions of customer
unparalleled shopping experience
and after two decades of innovation we
are now a global technology company
providing software Robotics and AI
solutions for online grocery
Google Cloud platform has been with us
on that journey and played a significant
role and as we grow as an organization
our presence on gcp has also increased
so today we are managing more than 3 000
gcp projects across various business
streams and reprocessing petabytes of
data on a daily basis we have to deal
with different type of users each with
variety of needs including data
scientists ml Engineers data analytics
product managers as well as some
external users so as you can imagine the
scale and complexity comes with a number
of challenges security is definitely one
of them and this is where my role and my
team is to tackle these challenges
amazing thank you for being here today
uh could you tell us a little bit about
how getting started with security
Command Center was at ocado maybe how
long it took or how rolling it out went
sure I have to dive into a bit into
history and a few years back we started
with uh self-hosted security scanners
they've provided us with uh really
meaningful info but we quickly
discovered that they just wouldn't cope
with the amount of assets we had
scanning of those assets was taking
longer and longer and would eventually
lead to inertia in our security response
which just wasn't acceptable for us also
we had to manage these tools ourselves
that included some maintenance like
upgrading patching reconfiguring
Integrations and that's an extra effort
we had to take which we obviously don't
want to we wanted to focus on resolving
security problems
the tool was managed by us centrally and
it didn't allow for any work delegation
and we realized it is a problem because
it creates bottlenecks in our security
process
so this is where we started to evaluate
Alternatives and security Command Center
was one of them
First Impressions extremely positive it
served really well as a single pane of
glass for our spectrum of security
challenges for example we used security
health analytics for our conflict
validation in bigquery GCS and Cloud SQL
resources
we had now reliable scans every 12 hours
which gave us much more confidence
comparing to our previous solution
I have to say the whole setup and
adoption was really really smooth and
thanks to the gcp doing a native gcp
service so for us this is there was
something we knew this is was just a
matter of setting up the right
permission catching up with documents
and that's it we after a few days were
able to see our first insight into our
security landscape
as you know sometimes appetite comes
with eating and we we're very eager to
try on new few interesting features we
heard about and that would includes
um things like instant scanning
um scanning with more comprehensive
security control lists permission
delegation which would solve our problem
I've mentioned earlier or even threat
detection we decided to upgrade to SCC
premium
that's great to hear it sounds like you
really benefited from uh Cloud native
solution there uh you also mentioned a
shift from centralized management to uh
delegation uh could you tell us about
that shift and how you manage the
delegation of posture issues out to
those business units
sure and atacado we truly believe that
autonomy drives Innovation and we always
want our teams to be self-sufficient as
much as possible and then we aim to
empower them so that they can move at
the right pace
and that's with everything else we just
applied this principle to security and
using access control at the folder level
we are able to delegate SCC findings
directly to relevant business units
this is how it works if I grant SCC
permission on a folder owned by a
specific business unit that unit will
receive only findings for assets from
that folder they will not be able to see
anything else including notifications
from other units this is not only great
separation of Duties but also it allows
owners to focus on issues related
strictly to resources they know most
about
we're really proud of our delegated
views feature as well did you use that
at all to help move some of your
Security operation tasks to Developers
yes indeed we actually built a whole
pipeline of of security findings we've
used continuous exports feature we built
on top of pops up and Cloud function and
that pipeline would automatically
generate a jira ticket which is then
assigned to developers they are usually
owners of other resource so from now on
they are in charge they can prioritize
and resolve the problems at their own
pace and this is this is how we surface
the autonomy of of the teams
awesome can can you share a little bit
about that process that they follow how
they're addressing vulnerabilities or
threats uh and remediate them in your
environment
yeah so going back to my to the team and
once they in control of a
misconfiguration
um in many many cases they they can
remediate the problem on their own
but of course we don't leave them alone
in this first the findings from SCC are
quite Rich they they really give enough
context to to be able to act and the the
findings would also include very
comprehensive recommendation uh on the
solution
um we also have Security Central
Security teams which they can always
consult if the issue is more tricky
but in case of Live security threats we
need to act slightly differently and we
need someone who more proactively
monitor our estate and here we have
another integration this time with
Splunk which is our Central CN system
where our security operations team
oversees the whole organization
I actually have one recent example
um famous log 4ga vulnerability where
our operations team was able to respond
pretty much instantly to to the live
attacks they've seen
and I have to say we were really
impressed how quickly this new control
for a completely new type of attack was
added to SCC
that really gave us that confidence we
we were looking for the confidence that
we can not only Leverage The Tool but
also the security expertise from Google
Cloud
I think we all remember log4j uh that's
great to hear
uh could you share a little bit about
how security Command Center helps
demonstrate compliance standards within
our to your stakeholders
yeah audit is always a big thing and we
we recently run an internal audience
across the ocado technology again STC
has been extremely helpful here uh
specifically in identifying projects
with the most severe issues
we were able to correlate projects with
business owners and generated a very
useful report for our auditing they were
really grateful because it worked for
them as an action list
another example is our initiative to
visualize our security estate
we created a security kit map which
Aggregates findings at the folder level
which usually corresponds to a
department or some kind of organization
division
and this visualization helps us to make
data-driven decisions prioritize things
or assign resources where they need it
great thanks again for sharing your
experience do you have any closing
thoughts for other folks who might be
considering security Command Center for
their needs
yeah the security Command Center has
proven itself for us and we are now very
very confident that going forward it can
serve as our Central security monitoring
tool so highly recommend
great thanks again for joining me today
matcha thanks team
to hear more about the topics I covered
today check out the videos from my
colleagues in the getting started with
security Command Center playlist on
YouTube or head over to our product
documentation links to hear more about
how security Command Center can help
with your security needs thanks for
tuning in
foreign